foreign
hope everyone
survive without broken pipes and
cars that were frozen and everything
else it looks like it's going to be a
balmy 80 degrees today
um in here
I think I'd like to start if the work
session first with a pledge and ask our
clerk if she would lead us
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty
thank you I think we neglected to do
that last time and
that was the one mistake I made all year
um I am opening the
work session
um on House Bill 301 that I introduced
last week
um
for those
that are new to work sessions
um you can think of it almost as an
executive session but in a much less
formal way
I'd like to try it so that we don't have
to do things through the chair we can
toss out ideas as we go
I would only ask that if you have
something to say that you still have to
use your your microphone and that will
indicate who to everyone else who wants
to speak
um but
as far as the content
it's anything to do anything that's
written on both sides well on mine it's
both sides of this sheet of paper or any
other idea on conflicts of interest and
and ethics is in general
um with everyone without exception
without objection I'd like to let um our
very fine uh ethics Guru
um Rich Lambert who's in the room
um also be able to participate and um
and answer any of our questions that we
have as they come along
I wanted to make sure we understood that
this bill is now in the hands of the
committee
um so all of the names that are on there
don't matter it is our committee bill at
this point so
um
don't think
um don't think that there's any
uh concern with
um
saying anything you want to I have very
thick skin even though my name is the
first one on there it doesn't matter it
is your it is all of our bill rather
than just mine okay
that being said
um
I
would like to just start out and maybe
start the the conversation rolling
by saying
um we have to decide somewhere and I
think right off the bat what's the
purpose of
having
this
um this section of our ethics booklet
is it to determine or or to provide the
Ethics Committee
a sheet
to determine guilt or innocence or is it
as I think
something that provides guide guidelines
I guess or suggestions or advice to our
fellow legislators to decide
um
how they
should be acting or or just a I don't
know brotherly advice is the right thing
but just some way some some offer of or
indication of how
um
you should have what you should have as
a guideline while you're determining
whether you have a problem or not with a
conflict
so
um that's that's what I think if anybody
wants to come up with a better solution
or a better idea of what that booklet is
the reason I bring it up is
if there is any concerns that I receive
back or feedback from any of the uh
people that have read it it's that
phrase in there that talks about people
who are close to you
and and funnily enough and I mentioned
this to someone over the weekend funnily
enough the people that had the most
problem with that are people that come
from the legal background
so the lawyers don't like that phrase
um and I and I maintain it's because
they are hoping to have they're used to
working with things that that give them
a sense of
guilt or innocence from how the wording
is is done and I'm not looking at it
from that standpoint
um so
um
I guess rather than just keep wandering
around here I'm happy to entertain
anybody else's thoughts about the
purpose of this and where we go from
here
Allison
hi so I also didn't like the someone the
legislator cares about um I thought it
kind of
I thought it thought it really
fell apart if like someone were to like
I don't know like need to pay back a
debt or something like that and it was a
conflict of interest
which like I hope no one's doing but
like
that would also be a conflict of
interest
um so I had I just looked up like
Massachusetts conflict of interest laws
um and I got that language drafted as an
amendment
um if we wanted to look at it if not I'm
fine with that
Jesus
that reminds me did anybody receive from
Jennifer the
um
I don't think she's done it yet I had
asked for
um I forget I think it was uh
representative payer that asked if we
had examples from other states
what's that we did receive that yeah we
have all 50 states it's categorized okay
in two separate that might have even
come from me now that I think of it I'm
not sure
um but um
there were a number of them that that we
no didn't see it
okay
I feel like I saw it but I didn't check
it out
this is the danger all right
February
first okay so that's just last week
right yeah and that had every every
state listed right because I also have
with me
from our work session over the summer
when we interim studied the bill I have
um
a sheet that we handed out then
and that just has some language from
other so from select States Oklahoma
being one of them Rhode Island Virginia
and and they'll those are the ones that
spoke to us as we're looking through
that entire list that we're talking
about you still need it all right
um
okay but you did receive the one from
Jennifer
okay
um
why don't you give me
the email addresses that you want that
sent to and I'll try to do it while
we're talking here
and then you'll have it
uh everybody else is okay with that
everybody else has it already
okay
um so what was it specifically
um representative Allison
um nutting Wong what is it that
you felt that the
the phrase didn't cover all instances
yeah yeah okay so here's another part of
that and maybe we jumped ahead a little
bit
another part of it is deter first
determining from this committee how far
from the legislator do we need to go
is it some states you'll see only go as
far as the legislator you that's where
the conflict begins and ends some others
look at the legislator and the spouse
some others look at the legislative
spouse and anyone that lives in your
household or is an immediate family
member and so on
I think that phrase that we used in here
encompasses all of those people and then
goes another step but maybe you want to
add it even further and say you know
someone that has debts you know whatever
the phrase yeah
um help yourself yep
I was specifically asked by my employer
to recuse myself from any bill that
would benefit them financially for any
Broadband type infrastructure bill
because that's who I work for so could
that be considered somebody you know
close to the legislator the employer I
would think so that's actually already
in here
and that's that part that that you
representative Tierney were were talking
about
um advocating for
or acting as an advocate in this case
should be acting as an advocate for and
there's another section as well well
right in the in the new language part C
says this person persons may or may not
include family members friends or
business associates and I would consider
that a business associate
yep by the way we have
um a lot of you haven't met
representative Constable representative
Constable watched us on TV last week uh
or or the week before I don't remember
um but um
now you can match the name to the face
so
you put us on the big screen
sure where to go with that
um
so um so again we you know I
we have certain sections that we could
either Silo this and just say okay what
do we think first of all how far from
that legislator we should go
and then set that aside and go to the
next section or we can
um you know shotgun this and go anywhere
we want to go
um what's the pleasure
if you
if you do it to where you put in
specifics instead of someone the
legislature cares about if you actually
put in uh relations and you go out to a
certain point
but then A legislature a legislator
cares more about two sections out or two
relationships out the new named
does he have to report it
is he guilty can he be thrown out
what gives
because somebody the legislator cares
about that's up to the legislator
that's not up to somebody else to say
maybe you don't like your grandchildren
for anybody who's got them
or at least certain ones of your
grandchildren I don't like your
grandchildren
and I've got 10 of them
but I mean
so
but if you've got great grandkids maybe
you care more about them than somebody
closer up but they're not listed this
lists them
without listing them I agree and our
point was to try to get away from
being a
genealogy band you know I don't want to
have to list every possible relationship
that
could fall into this cat into the
category that you would have to worry
about because certainly there may be
somebody's
stepfather's sister that you know you
that is in the same business that you're
voting on a an issue for that would help
them but I don't I don't that's why I
was trying to get away or we were trying
to get away from the
the guilt or innocence part of it
because certainly there would be a
loophole if you didn't name the specific
relationship that's what we're trying to
get away from what's that and that's why
the lawyers like that well there you go
yeah well I'm not going there
um but but I think that's part of it and
and so again I think a fundamental
question is trying to determine exactly
what we're trying to accomplish with
having this phraseology in an Ethics
book I don't know that that's well maybe
Mr Lambert can tell us has has that been
discussed in a
in an overall 30 000 foot view
um of what's the purpose of this ethics
book I know that they use the word
guidelines in places and I know
but but it seems that when you sit and
and
uh discuss a complaint
you are
you are seeking to determine guilt or
innocence at that point
um and that's what makes it
this conundrum
more of a question though but but that
it's still a guideline like they doesn't
that then come to a vote so it still
comes down to the house deciding right
on the ethics comes up with a
recommendation and they come up with a
recommendation right it's not guilt or
it's like we believe this per this
legislator should be censored perhaps or
expelled for something and then it comes
to the house right and then we have to
vote on it so it's still
you know it's not to me it's not a guilt
it is not
strictly written as law right it's more
to your point to me it feels more like a
guideline for legislators to when should
you recuse yourself and and it shouldn't
just be I agree that it shouldn't just
be family members right or business so
it should we should take that leap but
getting the wording right is a little
tricky as I think is
thank you
anywhere else
yeah
um I think the problem that I think with
this is that when we're using household
members it's easy to prove who your
household member is it isn't difficult
to prove who your friends are we're
having to write down our household
members and what you know conflicts we
might have because of where they work if
we get to going further and further out
I mean when we fill out our our ethics
sheet instead of just including
household members how like do we have to
write like our first 50 friends do we
have you know I mean like it gets it's
sort of it I understand the purpose of
it it's like a best practices guideline
more than than anything but like if
we're getting what we do here when we're
writing a law is unfortunately legal you
know it becomes important that we know a
distinction between whether somebody's
breaking the law or not breaking law
because we've created the law by putting
in special persons so that's I think
that that's what worries me is there
some way that
you could just move it to a best
practices thing and uh you know maybe
the the rules regarding whether or not
somebody gets brought up on ethics
charges
remains just household as opposed to
well I know this guy's friend does this
thing so I'm gonna complain sort of
stuff so that's my two cents yep anyone
else
I look at it as
one shoot morning
once you get to this point
and and
this probably tells you more about me
than anything else but I Envision the
poor guy the poor representative that's
sitting in the middle of a row
um so having difficulty getting in and
out and listening to testimony
and all of a sudden a name or a face or
someone he cares about someone he knows
he is identifying with that testimony
and he's thinking to himself
gee should I not you know am I crossing
a line here by voting on this issue and
and he doesn't have his family attorney
on speed dial so he does you know so he
can't find a quick answer I'm I think
that's the purpose of the book to and I
would like we talked about it last year
when we had the other bill
I would like to almost have a a one
little laminated sheet that
um that everyone is given that just says
um whatever we come up with out of here
you know if you have someone that you're
close to or someone whatever we end up
coming up with and they can just look at
it and we had talked about a decision
tree you know just having
um you know is this an issue that you
are aware of someone your your business
handling or whatever and coming down
just so that that person sitting in that
seat would have a better feel
for what they should do
and know that at the very end
if you still decide to go ahead and vote
on this
you are potentially opening yourself up
to a complaint
and or
tarnishing your
reputation and our reputation
collectively that's that's how
my mind has worked as we were working
through different work sessions and
executive sessions on the prior Bill all
of that that's that's how I'm trying to
reach a conclusion on this I don't know
if that helps or hurts we also have an
added Advantage aside from having Mr
Lambert here we also have another member
of the Ethics Committee and I don't know
how Janet that this
um
interferes with your you know where
where are your
where where do you yeah I don't know if
this interferes with your ability to do
your job in the other committee or here
not at all
um actually I some of us were wishing
that we had this Workshop or whatever
we're calling it this morning after the
Ethics Committee meets next Monday
because chairman of the Ethics Committee
former State Rep and former Senator Ned
Gordon is drafting language to help us
and he is very skilled at what he does
in a very brief and understanding way
um but I I think we're going the right
direction everyone's struggling with
this at this point and this doesn't
interfere with our work at all I had
mentioned to our chairman some weeks ago
that the only thing I came up with was
someone with whom the legislator is
closely associated rather than someone
you're close to
and representative nutting Wong has come
up with a wonderful beautiful amendment
that she's actually had drafted could we
look at that please sure absolutely
wouldn't we have the same problem with
someone that is closely associated I
would think that that's also is
what what you think is closer closely
associated right right yeah I that's
what I that's my initial reaction anyway
it's a chair yes Steve hi
um oh sorry a lot of a lot of these
terms that we're throwing around here
are going to have to be
extraordinarily defined
in a very rigid way because a lot of
these terms are ambiguous
they're subject to
mountain of interpretation
and
I have I have concerns when we talk
about cares or
Associates or
I'd need to know what that I mean okay I
went I went to college with people that
does that make them my associate does
someone I went to high school with make
them my associate does
is the Ethics Committee going to want my
Facebook friends list I
because when you use a loose term like
that people Define it in their own head
right it's
we look at that and go okay well in my
mind it means this
well that's all well and good
but in
representative payer's mind that might
mean something different
and of course when you get in front of
the Ethics Committee
there
not necessarily even going to agree with
something that's that's not rigidly
defined because in their head
they have a definition as well so
I don't know that it's we can talk about
generic terms like this but if we're if
we're not going to include a definition
of those terms with it and discuss a
definition
then we're going to kind of be I don't
know if we're really solving anything as
a as a collective
so I um
I think
the fact that you came in a few minutes
after the time we had talked that was
part of our original discussion of
whether we should have defined terms and
the fact that some some have not
appreciated the term those you care
about and and maybe now associate with
because you have to decide first
representative Pearson weather
what your purpose with this booklet is
is it to determine guilt or innocence or
is it and and that's where I think
um it sounds your headed so that so that
the um something is
is black and white or or uh
defined as to use your term in order to
um make that clear determination like we
do in a in a court
of any
substance
or is instead the booklet
there as a guideline to an aid the
representatives or the representatives
and Senators to determine
for themselves
because ultimately ethics is
what you think it is I in my in my
opinion ethics is what you do when no
one else is looking
um so for me it is more a guideline than
it is something that guilt or innocence
is going to be determined on if if you
think that this person that your college
friend
is to use the definitions that are on
the in the in the bill now
if you think your college
um roommate is someone that you care
about to the point that you would change
how you're voting because of your
knowledge of that person then yes
um that's
that's who we're talking about
um but if it's somebody that is
you know lives in your house that um
your son or daughter brought in
um and you don't know them then maybe
not you know that's that's where I'm
going well I can appreciate that there's
other folks on the committee that are
thinking along the same lines that I am
sorry about my tardiness but
um
your point for your personal
definition of ethics I don't disagree
with it's in here except when you walk
when you sit before the Ethics Committee
your personal opinion
is now really not it's part of the
equation
but you are sitting in in front of an
Ethics Committee board who's deciding
whether or not you violated the ethics
standard
so it's all well and good that your
personal opinion is framed in such a
manner
but the Ethics Committee is going to
make a decision
on the complaint that's brought before
them
and that
goes outside the scope of what you think
you did
and that in the guidebook that you're
referring to I presume will be part
of that ethics hearing
so that's not just a guidebook for the
individual legislator that's a guidebook
for the Ethics Committee as well
well maybe
maybe you would like to comment on that
oh I'm sorry I didn't see the hand well
I I understand where you're coming from
but it's critical as legislators that we
all understand if we step over a line
there are problems and I have brought up
before this committee before and well
again the fact that uh when I sat on
Judiciary we had a number of members who
were landlords and we also had a number
of bills that were landlord tenant bills
and it was very very important that
right up front these people say I'm a
landlord and yet this is what I believe
and this is my experience and so forth
if the person did not do that which did
happen that causes a problem because a
landlord clearly has uh different
opinions from a renter
and this this this is why we have to
have definitions and this whole issue of
conflict of interest I have an article
in front of me from the New York Times
last week with the U.S Supreme Court one
of the wives of the Chief Justice
actually his wife
um is
um being questioned
because of a possible conflict of
interest and that substantiated my
opinion in terms of the concept of
uh conflict of interest how did I work
let's see the legislator or one who is
closely associated with the legislator
or the issues with which the legislator
is dealing and again
um Allison excuse me
representative Allison netting Wong has
carried a step further and to clarify
and I think you might want to hear that
absolutely I just want to make notice
that the clerk did not mention a single
person recuse themselves from a vote we
took last week involving landlords
and if you're going to tell me that 400
members of of our house not a single one
of them owns rental property
I think you're crazy I think the number
is 40.
40 that own yeah okay not a single the
clerk did not mention a single recusal
so are we looking under the under this
proposed idea in 301 here are we looking
at 40 ethics violations
I'd like to respond to that if I may
please remember it's not just the single
type of uh issue you're talking about
you have to associate a lot of the other
parts of the guidelines it's critical
that we disclose that's why we have our
disclosure forms and these that's how we
yeah yeah but we do that now we're
asking to change this we do that already
I already I filled it out three times
in the three terms I've been here
so you're asking for a change we're not
I don't think where any of us are
debating whether we should have ethics
guidelines of course we should we
currently do what we're talking about
here is changing those guidelines from
what we have to something different
we're talking about clarification
because there has been some concern
among all members who have paid
attention to this and it's not to
criticize anybody but as all members who
have looked into this are concerned
about the definition of conflict of
interest and that's why this committee
is struggling to more clearly Define
that thank you
what
um I don't want to lose sight of the
fact that what prompted this bill and
most of the wording in this bill came
from the chair of Ethics last year who
who
um and if you read the first four Roman
sections here specifically called for a
change to how that book is so it it's
not that we're
it's it you're absolutely right we are
talking about a change but we're not
dreaming it up out of thin air we're
we're taking it from
the request of the chair of Ethics who
feels that they need that that's that's
the point but I agree I mean we are
talking about a change
um
at some point
representative McCarter had a question
but I don't know if we've already gone
past that or not yep
so I am
thinking this out loud here uh forgive
my ignorance however
it's on us to recuse ourselves from
something that would obviously
financially benefit myself my family
members who people we care deeply about
okay what if uh
my neighbor two doors down his wife
works at X company and something that's
coming up is going to impact her company
I don't know that's where she works
however she's my next door neighbor two
door's down what if somebody else
um on the legislator wanted to initiate
an Ethics complaint against me because
my neighbor two doors down works at X
company that I don't know it now it's on
me
to determine uh
that course of action I I
I'm just trying to navigate this that
what's the procedure what is the
procedure who who who uh lodges those
complaints is it uh
who defends it later so so we have two
people they can walk you through the
system go why don't you explain if
someone wanted to file that complaint
and thought that you had done something
that you shouldn't have voted or or
should have disclosed that this neighbor
was
how how would it operate go ahead
rich is here he can correct me if I'm
wrong on this one
um it depends on how close you are to
that neighbor if that neighbor has
considerable influence over your
opinions and your actions then it is
it's best if you do
disclose and recuse yourself if you feel
that you cannot be objective when it
comes to your decision making
I respect that I get that however uh
let's say someone else doesn't
understand that I'm able to make that
barrier and I'm able to make that
differentiation somebody else just knows
that so and so lives two doors down for
me and it probably did influence they
don't know that it didn't but they can
Lodge that complaint against me or you
or you anyhow where is the line that uh
you know who's off limits at that point
my my uh
former neighbor that moved to Florida
and his brother owns a company in
Nashville I mean like where where's the
line drawn
foreign
this is me speaking not
um you know any official ethics
um I I'm not a member of the Ethics
Committee
um no one can stop
another person from filing a complaint
against you right
so it would be then the job of the
Ethics Committee
to to
ask you to appear before them and and
they would ask you to explain
what you've just gone through
um this is my neighbor I see them yeah
you can make up any story you want you
know I I don't know the the complete
scenario but
but then they would judge
the veracity of what you're saying and
they would decide whether there was an
Ethics whether it was justifiable for
them to file an Ethics complaint against
you or not
um
we were somewhat careful in here to say
that
um you know this person just because
they lived there
it doesn't necessarily mean that you
wouldn't have voted that way anyway and
if and that
I don't know really how the ethics can
can judge that other than from what you
say in your frame of mind you know I
yes I am aware that that they're in that
business but here is how I evoted in the
past in these types of issues or
something like that
um
I it it will ultimately come down to
you're defending yourself against this
complaint
all I'm trying to say is
this booklet needs to be your
warning I hate using that word but your
title yeah you you need to be aware that
when you vote a certain way if you
choose to and not recuse yourself then
you are opening yourself up to that
ability to have a complaint lodged
against you which you will have to
answer to Is that does that answer what
okay
that's what I'm trying to get to or
that's the purpose of this meeting
yep
Mr chair I
I just see
uh for
for lack of a better term the activist
types to Lodge ethics complaints against
people absolutely I'm just I I agree
with uh representative Pearson that it
needs to be dialed in and very finitely
itemized
for that purpose
because once it's out there in the media
it isn't coming back it's out there and
right but it's within your power
to not have that be a weapon used
against you
that's that's the point and we don't
have that weapon
according to the chair of Ethics he is
in he believes that there is a need for
you to be able to defend yourself
using recusal
um so one of the things that
going back to my Commerce experience we
disclose things all the time but we we
rarely recuse ourselves from votes I
mean we're a citizen legislature so a
lot of the people that were on Commerce
had were business owners or landlords or
you know I served that you know going
back I live in a house now but at the
time I was living in a trailer park and
we had trailer park pills right so what
we would do is disclose that information
and put up front and to the to the
public and to especially an executive
committee we would disclose that this is
my conflict and but that we will
participate and I think that should
still be an option going forward so I
have a little issue with like
um where it says the legislative
legislator shall recuse himself I think
it should be may may recuse or disclose
right and
um I don't want to force us to oh
Commerce won't get done Commerce
Committee would not get done
okay because there would be
um
exactly and then what you would have to
do is then take the people that have the
expertise in those committees and take
them all for the committee
um and have them serve somewhere where
they have no experience and I don't
think that's what we want to do but what
we do want to do is make sure that we as
legislators as a citizen volunteer
legislator that we're disclosing that I
am a landlord but I will be
participating in this vote and and have
a clear conscience about that where you
should recuse yourself is where the
influence would change your vote right
if you're going to vote one way and
that's how you feel intellectually
that's how you're going there's no
conflict there's you you disclose an
interest but it's you don't have to
recuse yourself because that's how
you're voting where you need to recuse
yourself and this is a personal thing is
when that interest would change your
vote from a yes to a no from a no to a
yes that's right that's the ethical
violation and that's what it says and
that's what it says right but well up up
until 14c Dash Aces the legislator shall
recusing himself or herself from voting
um
where you know probably should be more
of a May recuse or disclose something
like that I don't think I disagree with
that there is also I and I don't think
this has been brought up but you
reminded me
um because we are a citizen legislature
one of the things that we
that we discussed heavily
um maybe more heavily than anything
we've talked about here now was the fact
that we didn't want to
stifle
specialized information that that the
legislator may have because of their
life experience so we specifically said
um under the exclusions or somewhere
here that if
if you are in committee or even on the
floor if you wanted to discuss or
testify or or that would just be done
with a disclosure as it is now
it was only the voting that we were
suggesting would be the recusal part of
it so we didn't want to lose the
institutional knowledge I'll call it I
don't I don't I don't think that's a
perfect term but
um
and we didn't want to I don't know if uh
this is the right term either but
um disenfranchised that person's
constituents that they represent
and they would be able to then testify
um with that disclosure and say I am a
landlord I am a you know a policeman I
am a whatever you want to say
however
um
at that point from that point on we felt
that that
um the suggestion would be not the shall
but the suggestion would be that you
avoid the possibility of
a complaint being filed by disclosing
and I think that's what this says that's
what I that's how I read it
yep sorry
I just have one question on
or for some clarification at the
beginning it says real or perceived
benefit
um
perceived by whom perceived by the
legislator himself or perceived by the
public in general
[Music]
no it's also in I'm sorry it also is in
uh I'm also talking about what the laws
what was your thought but either of
those with perceived I'm curious though
same but I was also trying to keep like
avoid the definitions of like an
interest
because it says um so in the original
Bill we have it says real or perceived
financial interest or non-financial
personal interest so in my amendment I
had real or perceived benefit Financial
or otherwise and at the end of the day
it's about whoever complains about you
like however they feel about it
like
um so it doesn't really matter what we
think but like you can get an Ethics
complaint about anything
um whether or not it's found to be
anything is another question I
understand that but that's why I'm
saying that I I myself can't recuse
myself from something because I didn't
understand that somebody else in the
state of New Hampshire would think that
I had a financial interest if it says
real or perceived by the legislator then
it's like yeah I think I might have a
financial interest in this so I
shouldn't do that that seems to make
more sense than just any but they all
think we have a financial interest in
this
so uh anyhow thanks
sure
can someone tell me who is able to fill
out a complaint
who can Lodge a complaint against a
legislator
anybody anyone public
anybody anyone from the public another
legislator anybody
that's long
as long as
they're aware of what our guidelines are
and what the real complaint should be it
there are people who do file complaints
that have nothing to do with the
committee
so it behooves people to make themselves
familiar with what constitutes an
ethical violation could we please hear
from Rich Lambert I think he could just
thank you I did have a follow-up real
quick
I don't know what the process is for
complaints
does the complaint go in front of the
Ethics Committee
yes yes and we're accelerating step by
step what to do okay
uh we need to get it on yeah I'm sorry
you can bring the microphone over there
now if you'd like no you really can't
well there are four
steps in a complaint one is when the
committee receives a complaint they need
to examine it and at that point they can
discharge it and so the situation that
representative MacArthur was describing
sounds like something that would be a
candidate but discharge if a neighbor to
house is down filed a complaint against
you for having
um if someone follows a plan to get you
for the fact that you know someone two
doors down from you
that would probably be discharged
because
it's pretty clear that that didn't
violate anything either currently or in
this bill
I would think can't speak for them but
the next step would be in initial review
and that's when the committee looks to
see if something is the complaint is
within their jurisdiction
and has Merit and at that point the
committee can dismiss the complaint and
unless the respondent waived
confidentiality all of that would be
confidential
the next stage would be the preliminary
investigation that too would be
confidential and then the stage after
that would be a formal hearing which is
open it's like a trial
so that is the process when the
committee receives a complaint it needs
to be the claim needs to be sworn to
before a JP or a notary and it's
confidentially filed and then supplied
to the committee members and to the
respondent
can you speak to thank you for that um
those answers
um can you can you speak to any of the
um I don't want to say issues or
situations but
but why are we why at this time was did
the chairman
indicate that we needed these changes
without speaking for him I understand
but
because
there is no place in the booklet
currently which requires recusal as
chairman Gordon said you won't find that
word in the booklet
and there were several situations
several complaints which arose and also
a request for an advisory opinion
describing situations and or involving a
situation or two where the legislator
thought he only needed to disclose but
it was found that he had both of them
had violated the section of the
guidelines called prohibited activities
which is on page
four
in the first paragraph
specifically says that disclosure does
not
um
save you so to speak from the
activities which are listed as being
prohibited
and so if you are being paid by an
organization to advocate for them
that would violate
several of these Provisions under
three to a through G
and that was what was found to have been
violated in two complaints
and also was talked about in The
Advisory opinion
in The Advisory opinion it was
um
I'll summarize as go forth and sin no
more kind of approach
where
would it is it fair to say that head
something like man this is a hard
question for you to answer but something
like what was available Lander 301 here
would have helped the committee
do more than just say go forth and sin
no more is that well I would hope that
it would have helped the
member not to have right not to I've got
to that point yes because the committee
and the two opinions two rulings in the
two cases both were resolved by informal
resolution
stated that the violations were probably
inadvertent because the legislator felt
that
all he had to do was to disclose
so but but the informal resolutions
were was agreed to as they need to be by
the respondent and both times the
respondent agreed not to vote on to he
agreed to recuse on anything that
affected his organization
what um
I'll keep jumping in here unless
somebody else wants to jump in at what
point
are what's what's the general feeling
what's your general feeling whether is
this in order to prevent
um cases to come before the Ethics
Committee or and to advise or is it to
um almost be a
um
the litmus paper that someone is judged
against
both there are five parts to this one is
the guidelines and sometimes I think the
name can be confusing they're not it's
called guidelines but in many cases
it is you know mandatory it's not
something you choose to follow because
you'd like to and violations of the
guidelines can lead to reprimand censure
or expulsion
um
in many states that they would call that
the code of conduct
but here for whatever reason it was
originally named ethics guidelines
but functionally it is a color of
conduct
then there are two laws in the booklet
one establishes the Committees
powers and duties and that begins on
page 25
and that is I mean there are violation
of that not only is a violation of the
ethics guidelines but in some cases
would be a misdemeanor
and then C RSA 14c which begins on 34 is
the Gift chapter
and violations of that also are a
misdemeanor
then the fourth part of the procedural
rules of the committee but how they
operate
um particularly with complaints and then
five has a number of other
miscellaneous Provisions
including the policy on harassment
which you'll discuss later and also two
interpretive rulings which were put in
here to help clarify what to do in terms
of acceptance of money for trips or how
to comply with the disclosure provisions
that one begins on page 64.
I do you recall last year when we had
the original bill I don't remember the
number of it uh you do
um
1368. we had talked about a a decision
tree approach have you had any more
thoughts about that or or has anyone
played with that idea because that would
seem to me if it's possible
that would be more leaning towards the
preventative side of this so that we
would have
um you should probably let everyone know
we we are on a dangerous path of of
complaints as well the Ethics Committee
has a has had a precipitous number of
of complaints in the last couple years
so I would think the preventative side
of things needs to certainly be part of
our discussion here in this work session
so
um that would be a great idea but I
haven't had to need to work on it I
perhaps that's something the Ethics
Committee can discuss next week also
does the has the Ethics Committee talked
at all about the possibility of having
some kind something to give to
Representatives other than a I don't
know how many pages we got here
representative wall has been a champion
68-page thing you know if you could get
it down to a
yeah yes a couple page you know so that
um that was we we have had that and I
also wanted to point out
um to build upon this whole issue of
disclosure
um on page 65 in the at the bottom and
Page 66 the Declaration of intent talks
about financial interests
um and that helps Define this whole
issue about if you have a neighbor who's
in the business or owns a business and
may have an influence over your vote
um it would have to go you'd have to
look at more than just that aspect of it
it would have to be and as it says here
if it affects you more or your household
remember whatever according to your
current definitions
um if there you'd accrue more benefit
than anyone else in the same position so
you have to balance all that in your
decision making sometimes that is enough
to help you decide sometimes it's not
and that's when people come to the
Ethics Committee and ask for us to to do
our advisory opinions
Mr chairman
um
one of the things that
I find interesting here is you know we
talk in the in the bill before us in
part C someone the legislative yeah it's
a rental uh someone the legislator cares
about
right but I find it very interesting on
page five under permitted activities the
first thing listed
is giving or receiving campaign
contributions it's amazing how fast a
legislature a legislator starts to care
about something
when it comes to campaign contributions
and yet the first thing listed under
permitted activities
so if we're talking about the Public's
perception if that's what we're really
worried about here is is perception on
the legislature
until that goes away
that's the Paramount issue is money in
politics so
and not only do we not even question if
it's prohibited or not we actually
listed as permitted
do I hear an amendment
is that what you're talking I'm going to
guarantee you right now that if I two
things will happen if I file amendment
to remove
campaign contributions out of this body
I'm a dead man and secondly it will
never fly and it will never pass so
that's a that's a futile effort there I
mean if you really wanted to go down
that road the executive Council would
disappear right so I'm trying to deter
determine what you're saying what I'm
saying is I'm trying to figure out what
the intent here is because if if the
intent is to fix a public perception
problem
then that's the number one public
perception problem politicians have
and we're not touching that
so so maybe you're talking about a
separate bill that you that you want to
I'm saying that I'm I'm trying to wrap
my brain around
when we're reading all these things in
here that guide us that tell us what to
do that give us Direction Why Don't We
Just leave it alone
I just don't you're not selling me on
the idea that we need to change this
that you know what I mean because we're
you know we're citing examples we're
showing procedure we're talking about
the book well this this is the current
Playbook
so
and we're concerned because there's a a
a large number of and accelerating
number of complaints sure tell which
tell us that there is
something that need we need to address
yeah but that may not be the we're also
being told by the chair of the committee
that
that he needs or they need
changes in order to handle the cases
that they currently have
I mean if they're getting an increased
amount of frivolous complaints then
that's I mean that's just what they've
just said frivolous
have these have these gone through the
process yet
all these complaints
I mean we don't without outcome we don't
unless the participants are open to uh
disclosure but so also but also it's not
um I'm looking over past years you know
if you look at the and we had it at one
point the the number of complaints I
think that was handed out actually at
the at the freshman orientation the
number of complaints over the past
um three years or something like that it
is clearly
clearly what we have here
[Music]
isn't either at either educating the
representatives to what they
um can or should do or
um we're doing more things that are
either publicly perceived to be a
problem or not or we figured out a way
that hey we can kind of weaponize this
and I'm going to give you an example you
want to talk about issues and ethics I
was threatened with an Ethics complaint
if I advocated for something something
that has no financial interest on me in
any way shape or form okay so that's not
covered in this except it is in the
sense that when they if they're going to
file the ethics complaint it has to go
through the process now I would think it
would get tossed
in the initial process but they'd have
to talk to me first because I'm being
threatened because I'm advocating for
something
that involves a board of directors I sit
on a board that owns no property has no
budget collects no tax money but because
I sit on that board they look at this
and say well you know your board member
says board member right
so this is the kind of crap that I think
is going to expand with this not not be
reduced
so that's that's my concern with the
language as it sits right now and
representative nutting Wong's got an
amendment that we're we're apparently
avoiding at all costs right now to talk
about but
um I don't know why would you say that
oh I don't know we just keep going off
on tangents and she's asked to do that I
was that was half a joke but
um
but uh my concern is that we've we make
this less clear with the proposed
language changes instead of tightening
it up
and I you know I
that's how I see it right now and I'm
trying to wrap my brain around doing you
know that going in the other direction
but I
perhaps for the explanation of her
Amendment would would help in that
process
thank you all right
um
I'll take your advice representative
nutting Wong do you have would you like
to discuss
the amendment and what prompted it and
what part of I still see that special
interest is in here which was taken out
of
that comes from the original language is
that right in the booklet
um so
um so my Amendment says conflict of
interest means the condition in which a
legislator has a real or perceived
benefit Financial or otherwise for
themselves or another individual that
would not be properly available for
otherwise similarly situated individuals
and for the most part that's just
language I stole from Massachusetts
um because I thought that it was way
clearer than what we were trying to add
and I thought it was a good starting
point for another like for this
conversation rather than arguing about
someone the legislator cares about or
what an interest is
um
you know there's other things we could
uh be discussing
um but I just liked it because I thought
it was clear that it made it
we didn't have all these weird
definitions and that was pretty much it
is she are you going to take any
questions Mr chair if we can ask in
reference to her we're in a work session
does this replace just so I understand
the the nuts and bolts of this does this
replace
all of one so there's no a b and c
anymore this is this becomes Roman
numeral one in its entirety yeah yep so
this replaces everything like in bold
so it doesn't deal with non-financial
personal interests or uh no that's part
of the
anything anything
I I
kind of like it more simply because
um the part about it where it would
available for otherwise similarly
situated individuals for example if you
have a friend that owns a car repair
shop and you're voting on a bill that
helps car repair shops everyone that
owns a car repair shop
is helped out by that not just your
friends sort of thing I think that this
is
a little bit clearer in the sense that
you can have friends that benefit from
votes because it's not about your friend
it's about the state and as a in a hole
so
yep
um I thank you for the amendment and I
don't want to be disrespectful but I
don't believe perceived benefit uh
perception is whatever your background
is it's
um
not measurable
um so I don't know that that would do
anything to decrease the number it might
even increase the number of complaints
if someone thinks there's
an Ethics violation there it might
Foster a complaint that wastes the
committee's time that's at least my
initial
my initial thought on that maybe I'm
reading it wrong
so I thought I came up with that but
turns out I stole that from the bill
itself
so that would be an issue we'd have no
matter what but yeah but yeah it is kind
of weird
can I say something else um that I I
didn't talk about earlier
um as a representative I think we all
come to the legislature with passions
and
um
initiatives things that we want to fix
for our constituents and I have actually
said in some of the thank you notes that
I post to newspapers that when I vote
on bills I'm thinking about my
constituents they are part of my quote
family now and I don't want that to
change because we are as Representatives
we are the relationships that we have
um and that's why we're doing this job
so
I worry about making it
so vague and open to interpretation
it's just my thought
is uh yep go ahead I guess I'm getting a
little bit lost here because in the
beginning we were talking about what is
our perspective so bring me back into
what the perspective is is this for me
or is this for the perception outside
onto me because the way I read this is I
read this for me and I need to make a
decision if I'm going to disclose or
recuse myself and I'm not worried about
what someone's going to complain about
me in this booklet or or is our should
our Focus be we're getting a lot of
outside complaints maybe they're
perceived maybe they're not whatever but
it's an outside influence on to the
legislators that we're trying to deal
with here what do we what do we because
that's I don't think you can split that
hair I think we have to make a decision
are we going that way or this way and
make that decision because I feel like
we're going like this on is this an
outside perception or is this for me as
a legislator
if you're asking me
if you're asking me it is it is to
advise you the legislator
um and to and to give get back to that
word guideline I think that's why or
code of conduct whichever you want to I
think this is to help you
know how to act
and give you the ability with this
legislation to give you the ability
um to know how you can avoid or lessen
the possibility of of a complaint
um that's that's what I think this
change does is give you the tool
in the knowledge of how you can lessen
um complaints lodged again you'll never
eliminate the possibility that someone
will do it
but but I'd also like to say that
um I think we have fundamental questions
because I agree with you we're starting
to go
with tentacles here in all different
directions I think we do need to
somewhere
say
how far from that legislator
um
we need to advise that the legislator
that he needs to worry about so as I
said there are states that just say this
only relates to the legislator himself
there are others that say this goes from
the legislator to immediate family
um
I don't know if we've ever even if we've
solved that issue first if we need to
know
how far does the legislator when we're
advising him need to expand his thinking
about a conflict yep would be helpful to
look at what the law currently said
States on this which is on page 25 where
a household member is defined
does
does the language
granted that some aren't happy with the
someone the legislator cares about
phrase
but does
it would seem to me
um that
phrase includes all of the
um
all of the people that are mentioned in
this in the current booklet yes and and
expands it beyond that
um that's that's how I Envision it that
that we are
um not shrinking the pool of concern but
we're expanding the pool of concern by
saying something
um as some have characterized it as
vague
um
because it's too difficult to list every
possibility and and household member
includes the someone the legislator
cares about
um that's a subset of that I think
well originally for many years it was
legislator and spouse
and then this was expanded to the
current definition about
15 years or so ago
and requires that the person live in the
same domicile
and share common economic interests in
the expenses of living in that domicile
do we Mr Lambert have
concerns or have we had cases where
it's not someone that lives in that
household
for example they're you know if someone
says gee my brother lives doesn't live
in that household but this guy is voting
on a bill that benefits his brother
um
is that not
is that not an expansion that would be
fairly common I would think I mean I I
don't recall any complaint there's been
about 110 complaints since 1992. the
committee started
yeah
um
from my standpoint that would be
and the ones that I've heard anecdotally
in my community it's
um and maybe it happens more when we're
talking about Selectmen and and uh and
that level but
there are always situations where
someone says
um
you know sure he voted for that his
brother is a Timber owner and he's
voting for you know um and I'm getting
nods around so it it does
um I have heard it so I'm surprised that
there aren't if you say that there
aren't uh
um complaints along that nature maybe
it's just grumbling and people move
along and figure there's nothing they
can do about it I don't know well you're
describing might invoke the prohibited
activity section but it depends on the
specifics you're right everything's the
devil's in the details right
yes sir
I'd just like to make another point that
um in New Hampshire are citizen
legislature is 400 people we don't have
lawyers at our disposal we earn a
hundred dollars a year unlike the other
states that earn much more money and
have lawyers at their disposal I think
looking at other states doesn't
necessarily help us
just
thought
it's possible that's true
you know
representative turcott Do you have a
you've been strangely silent along this
whole way here
all right all right
I don't want to run by anyone that has a
comment that uh
or yeah please hello
um I didn't mean to to scare you into it
I'm just new obviously I've been here
um so what I just wanted to comment that
I the book I honestly got this book at
orientation I skimmed it I didn't read
it thoroughly now I'm reading it
thoroughly
um but just what I thought was helpful
is in the back on starting on page 64.
they give examples about
what is a conflict when would you
disclose what what are your steps so
perhaps a suggestion could be to add
more whatever is hitting the Ethics
Committee now for violations perhaps
some of those examples could be
Illustrated as what a proper procedure
would be and you know kind of give more
examples I just find that examples are
really helpful to interpret what these
rules are all saying because the
language is heavy and especially if it's
lay people reading they might just see
something and be like they're violating
the law and get all up in arms but you
know if you have when you read these
examples in the back it kind of makes
things more makes a lot more sense to
everybody so I just think maybe EXT
expanding that
examples of how you interpret these
rules would be helpful yeah I uh I don't
disagree at all with that I I've always
done better with the
um what happened in what situation and
and how does it come close to my
situation
um and to point and to go along with
your agreement that someone may read
this and say oh you're violating my
um read on page one the under the
principles of Public Service
Roman 4.
that is
he was mean to me on Facebook
um I'm gonna file a complaint
it's it's crazy
um but you can read that that way you
can say he uh treat the public with
dignity and respect um
he he called me a bad name on Facebook
and I'm gonna file a complaint and and
make him miserable am I not accurate
that is what caused the increase in
complaints exactly
is the social media or number four or
both the social media and then people
looking at number four and filing a
complaint
so Mr chair
if I understand you correctly the
problem
that has come forward for the most part
is due to social media type complaints
brought to the Ethics Committee Against
members
just so I understand that yes and I have
some material for the
hearing on 157 this afternoon which
includes material I gave sent to
representative Hill
so I was going to talk to you about what
that one okay so so yes that
and it's not I don't think it's the
committee is concerned about their
workload what they're concerned about is
members of the public saying well this
legislator did such and such a thing
that clearly falls under number four and
so I'm filing a complaint and then the
committee says well this is just a
aspirational
provision
and so we can't sustain a complaint on
violation of that and then the members
of the public lose respect for the
committee and for the legislature
that's what Vice chairman scitec stated
during right one of the committee's um
discussions of this right can I follow
up with with my line with him sure okay
so if that's the problem if that's the
if that's the big concern that exists
right now how does House Bill 301 solve
that it's not the big problem not the
only problem okay but you just said that
was the that was the chunk of the issues
that we're not debating here we're just
saying it's not a matter of debate I'm
trying it is that
the tone is will you use this phrase
what I'm what we're saying is there are
a number of
um
uh complaints that have come forth
that's not the sole reason that there's
a spike in in complaints is number four
that's not the case what what he's
saying is he has they have received
these complaints and and people are
using this as
guidelines rather than aspirations
um
we are pointing out that there is a
problem with number four but it is by no
means the soul problem it isn't what
prompted the chairman from from writing
the original bill that we had last
spring
does that help you
no it does it doesn't matter because if
that if that's I'm just we're talking
about dealing with an increase in
complaints if if the overwhelming
majority of those increasing complaints
have to do with with part four this this
bill before us doesn't address that
that's that's what I'm trying to I don't
think House Bill 1368 or 301 Were Meant
to affect that right there's more than
one problem this is what I mentioned is
one problem but the other problem is
when complaints arise such as the one
against the Senate President a few years
ago or involving
um former
Democratic member of the House who was
involved employed by a union
that's that's what it's meant to address
I'm going to suggest
um
as long as there's no complaints at a
10-minute
biological break
until uh until 10 30 or so does that
anybody have a problem with that thanks
I'm going to give you credit for that
one that's the first time I've heard it
described that way so uh you heard it
here first
we're back
um Everybody made it back right yep yep
oh no
um representative
excellent
um try not to say anything noteworthy or
we have to explain back to her then
we'll be good
um
so I don't know here's my plan and and
I'm open to suggestions
um I I would like to hear the input from
the Ethics Committee
so somewhere I'm I'm thinking we do this
for you know another 20 minutes or so
maybe to 11 o'clock
and then recess the
um the work session to after
the Ethics Committee meets next Monday
at three yes
um and then and then we either take this
up we'll we'll talk about it
um individually
of when we can do this and and see if
we're any further along after we get
input from them
does that seem reasonable
um I think
I don't think we can do
I don't think we should take any action
of of amendments or anything
notwithstanding your Amendment
um I actually would like to suggest that
um Janet bring your Amendment
to the Ethics Committee on Monday just
as a another piece that they can discuss
if anyone else has further things that
they would like to have Ethics Committee
amend or or look at I that would be all
right with you get make sure I get a
copy and make sure
representative wall gets a copy that she
can bring to the Ethics Committee
um
but again that you know you're not under
any obligation to do that I'm just
saying if there is something that you
want to at least say what do you think
about this
um it would save time in the process of
trying to get to that point this is our
bill right
um so
um we we're doing our due diligence to
try to get as much input as we can
from whatever Source but
um
uh with that
we kind of are are at this point of of
almost breaking down the bill into
different areas that we have to decide
so we talked about a couple of them one
is one of which is
what's the purpose of this
um and and I think it probably is a
little of both that we're talking about
either is it is it the guide that and
and as a preemptive book or is it a um
the the
rule book that will be judged against
should a complaint be filed in in the
Ethics Committee
um
I tend to look at it more as the as the
former
um that it is
the more we can help the the
representative make their own decisions
I think that's a good thing
um then we have to start getting into
those questions of how far it is from
the legislator that we need to worry
about or advise the legislator then we
need to get into
um what what types of issues
one of the things that's very odd in
here
um and and I'm not sure how this is
dealt with but let's we've only ever
talked about one side of The Ledger
when you vote to benefit someone or
someone that's close to you or whatever
language you want to use what happens if
you're voting against can you can you
then vote is it okay to vote if you're
going to hurt somebody yeah I mean if
you're or if not
um
is it just a blanket you should not vote
when this is a when there is a conflict
or is it only
you shouldn't vote when
it's something that is actually
benefiting someone
not voting against it you know if you've
always had voted against I'll pick an
issue um Charter Schools let's say
you've always voted against every
Charter School issue
but now your your brother-in-law is
runs a charter school
is it only meaning that you shouldn't
vote
um
in favor of charter schools or can you
still continue to vote against charter
schools that
better explained that's that's I don't
know I don't know the answer to that but
yeah kind of worms open yeah can of
worms well other states do have the
detriment in there and I don't know that
it really I think the real Crux of it is
is benefit so if we had to focus on one
thing I would keep it at as as a direct
or indirect benefit but other states in
that thing do have
um benefit or detriment so they they do
add it and so regardless of it can go
either way benefit or detriment and
really comes down to the influence and
what it has over your vote so if uh you
if you hated somebody and you did it
just to nudge them technically in some
states that would be for they they
should disclose and recuse uh what they
should yes we have that
already already
on page 18 if you look at that
in the first paragraph on the sample
form of the Declaration of intent form
where is it page 18. yeah first
paragraph
third sentence
beneficial or detrimental
um
so nothing am I correct in saying that
wouldn't that we're not changing any of
the forms with 301 so that would still
remain as for disclosure
what about recusal would it be the same
it could
well I mean
um
yes I would think so okay but maybe that
should be more specifically stated
somehow in the word right
um
maybe it should just be
said benefit well as it does here either
beneficial or detrimental that's all you
need to say right that recusal would be
an option
um
there what was the other section that I
had uh
thought oh um
there's another piece in here that is
very important I think and I think
people should
think on this
um
to me it doesn't matter if anyone else
is getting this benefit
similarly situated as it is now in this
book to me if you are getting the
benefit
or or someone you care about is getting
the benefit
that's all that matters it doesn't
matter if there's there's you know other
other financial advisors are getting the
benefit it they're not voting on it you
are is the way I look at it I don't know
if that's
um
I don't know if that's a good way to
think or not but that's how I think of
it yep
problem with that is where do you cut it
off in other words
you own stock in a t i own stock in ATT
we vote on something that benefits them
I am far far far far far far far from a
major stockholder in at T
okay
I'm getting no more benefit than anybody
else but if their stock goes up I'm
getting a benefit now do you put it at
you own two percent of the stock of the
company is it got to be 10 of the stock
of the company
you run into a problem because everybody
out here if you own a mutual fund odds
are you own stock in most companies
they're spread out all over the place
where do you draw the line
so yep do you want to go
we've thought about that you've talked
go ahead me gasping yeah
it brings to mind a situation where a t
was an issue before us right
there was a whole line at the clerk's
office to file and actually we were
going overboard it's a few benefit more
than somebody else currently yeah yeah
currently
um
but none of those
and and maybe the way to handle it is
the same way we've put in here for the
exclusions to recuse all that you know
it wouldn't apply to the budget because
virtually all of us have something in
the budget that that
affects us somehow you know and and
would be eliminated from having a quorum
if everyone
excluded themselves from that there's
also an exclusion in here for General
Revenue bills or bills of such great
interest where a large percentage of the
members would be affected as to cause a
problem with Quorum so
I kind of put it in that category maybe
there needs to be something different
it's obvious I can't see that anyone
said would come back and file a
complaint again if I'm looking at this
as an advisory thing for the legislator
I can't see anybody coming back and
saying I'm in I'm in danger of
of having an Ethics charge filed against
me because I own Vanguard you know
Capital Growth Fund um
it I understand your point but somewhere
along the line you can drag this thing
out to it you can grow it out too far
right the lunacy this is a guide to each
individual and only a guide everybody in
this room should have an Ethics standard
that they built up over their lives
okay they should it may not be a good
one but they've got one of some way
shape or form this is just a guide to
give them okay maybe what I'm thinking
this thing says it's not the best idea
okay maybe I change maybe I don't
but you've got an Ethics background
already
so it's not for everyone else and if you
think it's for everyone else
then you really are a politician and if
you don't want to think your of yourself
that way then it's got to be for you
only
I don't think I could have said that any
better
but well I have a question then and and
I
I think we need to clarify this
foreign
the words in this book is this the
standard to which the Ethics Committee
makes a decision whether you've violated
the rules or not is this the standard
the ethics because if it is this is not
a guide
this is a standard well it's really both
um but anyone can file a complaint
against you if they feel that you
violated one of the provisions in the
booklet
and there are other Provisions which are
misdemeanors if you violate them
which which is if the gift materially uh
well you must know yeah if you
materially uh re don't list every one of
your
um
real or perceived benefits or
if you leave off
knowingly leave off something off your
statements yes exactly that's where the
misdemeanors come and also violations of
14c which is the gift but I think the
bigger I to me the bigger part rather
than the book I think the bigger part is
then that those steps that you mentioned
earlier the um the initial conversation
I forget the phraseology they used for
that initial review the initial review
um
that's
that's a bigger piece of that
determination of whether you are in
violation or not then this and then the
next step when you're actually brought
in if they if you pass that or don't
pass that initial review that's a bigger
step than this
um
it's it's I I think we still come down
to that I don't know what the percentage
is to me
this is 80 percent guideline 20 percent
um whatever it is you want to call it
the uh the sentencing guidelines you
know I mean this is yeah that's a bad
phrase isn't it
um
this is um this is more aspirational and
and more but I
Beyond just the guideline it's also
the to me the ability
to to advise
the legislator how to mitigate or lessen
that
chance of a you can't eliminate but the
chance of a complaint being filed
against you
that's that was what 301 was is about
yep
question
uh the Ethics Committee
anything you decide in the Ethics
Committee
is that final other than removal uh
thrown out of the house uh which has to
go to the full body or does anything you
come up with have to go to the full body
any sanctioned
that's recommended as a recommendation
by the committee to the body
now that can be informal resolutions
where the respondent agrees to
that he or she did something incorrect
and they'll take certain steps to make
sure that doesn't happen again
and that is what we had in the two
complaints I mentioned and that was
internal to the to the committee that
never went to the floor no it was
published in the calendars though yes it
was public
okay so you act as
quasi judge
which means you follow this but like any
judge
your ethics background might say well
something in here might not be exactly
right and for how and if others agree
with you on the committee
that could be
put aside yes no or are you bound and
you have to
adhere to every single you know uh thing
that's in there the committee
will decide if a complaint is has Merit
or not
and
at the end of the certain process at
certain points they make a
recommendation to the body
reprimand censure or expulsion
but the devil is in the details right I
mean right it's impossible for them to
write it yeah and and and put all of the
relationships and all of the other
things that that could be affected
um somewhere along the line it does
become
judges yeah and then how they interpret
it and interpret your
your circumstance your circumstance and
your explanation of the circumstances if
you wish to see those complaints which
were public or on the committee's
website
and you you can see those which have
gone to a special to a formal hearing
have resulted in a special report which
are pretty lengthy and or pretty much
like a court decision
and you can see how they go through each
of the charges and what they find with
their findings on each
my concern has always been
and you spoke to it earlier that every
all of us come with our own
level of ethics and
but somewhere there needs to be a
recognition that because we are A
legislature
your ethics and your ethics and your
ethics
um affect my ethics or or My Reputation
or my anything
um and that's also part of this you know
we aren't operating in a vacuum and and
so
um
we get tired with that great big brush
along the way that's what you have to be
careful of well among everything yeah
yep yep so so if this is if we're
treating this as as a a guide for the
Ethics Committee can we get a copy of
the actual
rules that they use to make their
decisions if this pink purple book is
not that dot not that set of well rules
the committee's rules are in the booklet
oh the committee's procedural rules are
in the booklet okay so they are so they
are then judging a member's complaint
based on what is in this book Yep
they're getting on page 40.
foreign
full disclosure one of mine is it mine
printed in here no it's on the website
though mine is on the website
um
it gets into that
um what's the category what's the
phraseology the
um better to ask permission than
forgiveness or vice versa
um
I always thought
especially with this kind of thing that
you're better off
discussing it before it becomes an issue
um but I wasn't aware that the Ethics
Committee would do that
oh sure so you can go to the Ethics
Committee and say I have a particular
scenario that I'm concerned about and
they will make a preliminary decision
based on the circumstances you present
before them yes on page 27 I keep
telling you to go to different pages but
page 27 RSA 14b3
paragraph ID I'm sorry C
talks about one of the committee's
duties is to render advisory opinions
and that those get published in the
calendar Steve
what there are their opinion on a
question gets published in the calendar
it's public yep so I'm I'm I would I'm
guessing but I'm fairly certain that
you've been here and got a calendar that
had one of those listed on the front
page
yeah
in the community can issue interpretive
rulings on its own motion also if it
hears there's confusion and or something
that needs to be clarified and which is
what those two items are at the back of
the booklet those are interpretive
rulings
see why it's 68 pages long
it's in here it's just
um
I I don't know many people uh that are
legislators and have been legislators
for years
that are confident they know this book
and that has always well
you've been here how many terms now it
it
right it is
um always if you ask anyone when they
filled out the forms every year or every
two years or whatever we're doing now
um
are you confident that well I filled it
out the best way I know how
um but but no one has a level of
confidence that they are
doing everything the way that they're
supposed to be doing it and that's not
right to me to me that's where this
guideline that's where this book needs
to be simpler with less definitions and
and more again aspirational here's what
here's how we should be operating
individually because we do
affect all all of us collectively
that's how I look at it
it's a moving Target that's going to
stay a moving carpet it's not going to
change
okay
when my father your father whatever
microphone thanks when my father your
father whatever were in the military
Way Way Back
you could tell a dirty joke
you can't now
okay somebody might be offended okay
somebody might be offended by something
you tweet or put out on Facebook
Roman four yeah but you can't do that
anymore somebody might be offended later
on because you were a tweed jacket
okay that might offend somebody
that may come out that may come out
later on that okay that's grounds for
this it's a moving Target that always
changes
based on societal norms
evolves yep
I think when this bill first came to us
the point of the bill
was for whether or not we should decide
should we recuse ourselves for somebody
that is outside the family member
outside of your spouse or or somebody
that you care about that was that was
the original language and we have an
amendment with some different language
that's what I think we need to be
focused on here do you do we agree or
not agree that we should take that step
further to go beyond the household is
that if it is somebody outside of your
family
has influence over you
is that it's something that we should
put in the ethical guidelines to say you
should disclose or recuse your vote I
think that's what we need to figure out
here right I mean that's what the bills
is it's a recusal
or a a a disclosure
of somebody outside of our family and
are we okay with it is that what and and
if that is the case if the the general
feeling is that that's something that we
should do then we can dial in on the on
the language on that is is yeah it's a
moving Target it's all that all of that
this whole there's a whole book it we
can be here for like three years going
over this but do we want to take that
step beyond the family
um you know are we comfortable doing
that and then then it just becomes a
matter of it's our bill right it becomes
a matter of how we how we Define it we
can Define it any way we want to it's
our bill now right so we can amend it to
but it's that first step is
are we going to go there it's uh and you
know I mean personally I'm comfortable
taking that leap I think it is an
ethical violation of my best friend if I
if he he or she
um has a material interest and I'm
influenced by that decision I feel
personally like that should be a
guideline in this book to say you at
minimum have to disclose and make it
easier to recuse your vote on that one
and and um because sometimes it's not
easy to recuse yourself especially if
votes are close right but we need to
make it clear that no this is something
that we probably should step back from
on this vote
um and that's that's the step we we need
to figure out
what to go in there
sure
uh as
um someone who takes the Constitution
very seriously
if
a vote that someone perceives might
influence or might be influenced by
a best friend or someone in my family
um violates the Constitution or my
constitutional oath
where does that leave me
do you see what I'm talking about no I
don't what if what if um
I am I use the Constitution as
my descent my litmus test whether or not
to vote on a bill
if someone fills out a complaint that
they think I violated my ethics or
ethics
because of that vote where does that
leave me
does that ever happen
you can't have two litmus tests do you
know what I mean yes well the committee
is always refrained from interpreting
the Constitution that's for the courts
to do
um so they would dismiss because I
probably
um unless there was some other
if they found there was some statutory
or other provision that was violated
I think I've read
at least for the time that I've been
here since 2010 I think I've read all of
the all of the possible ones that I've
and I haven't seen anything like that
that violates yeah I haven't seen anyone
say I voted this way because of the
Constitution I don't it's I don't just I
don't know that I've ever even read the
word constitution in any of the
complaints that come there so if that
helps you I don't know no not really
bless you I'm sorry
um moving on I I getting back to rep
Constable's um
suggestion
I think you're right I think there's
that's that is a key question how far
from that legislator do we go
um do we go past this idea of household
member
um and the definition that includes
financial interest similar Financial
interests within the
I don't know how
how far beyond that and that is one of
the fundamentals but there's about four
fundamental questions that we have to
add just a couple of words someone with
whom you're closely associated
might be the might be the winning phrase
I don't know
um but again it's still we still have to
answer his question which is how far
beyond the family do we go
it's entirely possible that you're very
very close to someone beyond your
immediate family I mean it happens all
the time right and so it's entirely
possible you're involved with someone
who who's a financial advisor or
something
um you need to make that call
comments we went past my 11 o'clock semi
deadline but um if
are we at a good place to stop and
wander off and think about and read
maybe more carefully the the 68 pages we
have and then
um what does everyone think about the
idea that we come back after ethics
meets and talks and maybe has
suggestions for us there may be in
addition to uh representative nutting
Wong's Amendment there may be
others from them but there may be some
from us as well so all I'm asking is
that I'd be made aware
and also probably representative wall be
aware if anyone's working on an
amendment and and you know
if nothing else we can act as a
coordinator if there's two people that
are acting on the same kind of an
amendment we will would be happy to link
you two up and so that there's something
similar but um
I don't know how you feel I feel like
we're at least having the conversation
and that's a good thing
um
we will become somewhat of a resource to
our fellow legislators
in this fashion because
I would almost guarantee you that we
know more about this issue after these
three hours than or two hours than
anyone else sitting in reps Hall on
February 14th
um
well
just because rich is there we're gonna
all know more but that's a whole other
story
um so that's that's
it it is an important topic it's
probably one of the most important
topics that this committee is has taken
up in the last uh
three or four terms yeah
um so I I appreciate you
your attention and your comments and and
uh
I'm happy to discuss it with any of you
anytime offline
with that um I'll close the work session
on uh
301 and
um our hearings start at
one
make a nice long lunch I guess
um if there's anything uh anyone needs
I'm gonna be hanging around here for a
little while
um but um
but we should be in we have three bills
on
before three
um
and uh I don't know about you but I'm
looking forward to all three of them and
then we'll um hopefully we'll be done
with all of our bills
with the exception of
a work session and I haven't scheduled
purposely an exec session
we have until March 15th to get all of
our bills out
I think if everyone agrees I think we
can probably get
all of our bills done with one day
one vote one day
seems fair right seven uh
and uh and we obviously we always have
the choice if we want to retain
something but I'd prefer not to
um
that's all I know at this point so I
haven't scheduled anything you haven't
missed anything if if you're thinking
that when are we going to do this and
everyone else is exacting and we aren't
don't worry
um we're under control all right thanks
very much
see you at one
foreign
yeah
if I can interrupt for a minute
um there's going to be a quick uh five
or ten minute caucus by the Republicans
and the Democrats Republicans will stay
here Democrats will use the office
thank you
so the time being uh four minutes past
one I'll open the hearing on House Bill
134 and welcome not the prime sponsor
but someone speaking to it right uh
representative Mike Edgar
uh has asked for two minutes
welcome to legislative Administration
thank you
as you said my name is Mike Edgar I
represent Hampton
and uh
I found out by uh thank you Mr Mr
chairman and the committee members you
know for allowing me to introduce hb134
to you today
the bill establishes the legislature as
a public employer under the public
employee Labor Relations Act and
establishes procedures for collective
bargaining by non-partisan employees
the legislature will join the judicial
branch and other state agencies which
already have a place a program as public
employees under the public employee
relations act
this Arrangement has been worked well in
other government entities employees are
given a choice as to whether or not to
form a union
existing job action and strike laws
would apply
instead of me going through the the
history here I have written for you I'll
just basically say that there's been a
lot of activity on this you know from
1998 to 2022.
um the interesting part is that one year
it passed in the Senate and not in the
house another year passing the house not
in the Senate
um
but
non-partisan employee means an employee
whose purpose is to serve the
institution of the general court rather
than to shape and Implement policies
that reflect the positions of elected
officials
non-potest employees shall include
employees in the following offices
the general court Administrative Office
legislative budget analyst assistant
excuse me legislative Services
legislative operations Health Services
General Court technology Services
Visitor Center Protective Services Chief
Operating Officer the speaker's office
house clerk's office house sergeant and
imam's office house committee Services
Senate president's office Senate clerk's
office Senate research office Senate
committee services
Senate administrative assistants
Senate legislative aides and Senate
legislative assistance
quite a few people let it sound
please consider giving these
non-partisan employees a chance to
choose and vote OTP
and thanks for letting me speak and we
might have some questions
you'll take questions please are there
any questions for Mr representative
anger
I want representative Conley
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here as well and thanks for taking
my question
um I'm guessing I just need
clarification on this that this is
obviously different with public
employees than say for example private
employees they specifically need our
permission in order to join a union
whereas in private practice they have
the right to form a union is that
correct uh that's my understanding yes
okay thank you no further questions
thank you for answering my question
thank you any further questions
I have one
um do you know from the list that are
here how many employees we're talking
about
um Paula you're gonna hear that in a
minute uh from somebody who knows more
than I do
well that covers both of us
thank you very much for your help then
um I don't see any further questions uh
we're good thank you thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you today
chair as only one other pink card
and that's from our very fine house
Clerk
honorable Paul Smith
setting me up for failure Mr chairman uh
good afternoon Paul Smith Clerk of the
house
um again uh as those of you who have
heard me talk before I'm testifying
neither in favor nor opposed to the
legislation just presenting you some
informational uh points
um I wanted to just go over briefly some
of the numbers uh Mr chairman you asked
the question about total staff for the
general court there are over 100 General
Court staffers total and that does
include both the house the Senate and
Joint however I do want to bring up a
couple of points specific to the house
because this is obviously where we are
at this point there are 24 full-time
house employees pursuant to this bill
six of those are politically exempt
meaning three work in the Republican
Office three work in the Democratic
office uh according to past labor
practices
supervisors are usually exempt from
these types of of bargaining units as
well and that would affect at least an
additional six the chief of staff and
the Deputy Chief of Staff the clerk and
the assistant clerk the commission
excuse me the director of committee
services and the deputy director of
committee services so that brings us
down to 12 house employees that this
legislation would potentially impact
and I think it's important to know that
I'm in my 18th year on staff here in the
general court staff has never been
surveyed on this issue staff has never
been approached those that are within
these bounds so to speak have never been
asked if if we desire to be a member of
any collective bargaining unit
I would I would also note that the
unique nature of the legislature is that
the speaker does rely on institutional
Knowledge from most people here most
people in the legislature uh in terms of
the staff spend their careers here most
of them start when they're in their 20s
and will often leave when they're in
their 60s so the the turnover rate here
in the legislature is not high that
being said this is a political
institution this is unlike an executive
branch or judicial branch because the
judicial branch obviously the the
persons that run the judicial branch are
all there for a very long time as well
on their own rights in terms of the
leadership because they are appointed
until they're in 70 years old
the nature of the executive branch is
even though the chief executive does
change over every two years the ship of
state government does not not stop every
two years regardless of of who the
captain of that ship is uh and so the
the the nature of government is that
government continues uh the legislative
branch
um
we change over every two years uh you
you know in this body alone we we
typically have about a third the change
is over every two years this year we
were a bit above that we were close to
160 new and returning members uh and
that has definitely affected
perhaps the makeup of the chamber
and having the speaker have the ability
to have those persons that the speaker
historically relies on usually the the
nonpartisan staff stay in their
positions is inherent in the trust in
the system uh that being said
there are times when we do get actors in
this uh in this branch of government
that do Advance beyond their uh their
their political so to speak involvement
and the speaker has historically and and
the mind of many should have that
ability to surround him or herself with
the people that are here to advance the
institution and I would just note that
in Massachusetts our very labor-friendly
State uh to the South uh this past year
an attempt was made in the Massachusetts
Senate to unionize and the Senate
leadership the Senate President and the
chair of the Ways and Means Committee
basically said given the unique nature
of their legislature that it did not
make sense uh for them at that time
and again I go back to those to those 12
people in the house that could
potentially organize I'm aware of at
least four state employee uh unions that
represent all of the state employees
across different different bodies and
you could potentially have 12 people
represented by four different collective
bargaining units which might make things
a little bit difficult for our house
legislative facility subcommittee so
thank you any questions happy to answer
are there any questions for
yes representative
McCarter
thank you thank you Mr chair has there
been any research done with regards to
the fiscal impacts of
um
getting into this kind of an arrangement
uh there is there isn't a there is a
fiscal note on the back here
um we we have had this this is not the
first uh time we have seen this bill uh
obviously there there would be uh costs
associated
um in in terms of in uh certifying votes
Etc so those are costs those are not
borne out in this in this fiscal note
but uh those those are known things
thank you any further questions
being none thank you very much
I have no other pink cards uh unless
anyone is hiding one
um
is there anyone else in the audience
that would like to testify
seeing none I'll close the hearing on
House Bill 134.
and we have 15 minutes before
we open our next
House Bill 157 which gives us a perfect
time
for those who haven't met we have a new
committee assistant
and if she's listening through the door
there she is see see
um
this is Jamie um I I'm assuming you're
fine with us addressing you as Jamie or
okay
um welcome to the legislative
Administration this is her first first
full week right
um but uh anything that uh you have for
questions
um feel free to ask Jamie and then
she'll shrug her shoulders and say I
don't know go ask the chairman and uh
or Jennifer yeah that's how to do it
um
everyone say hello Jennifer uh Jamie
thank you
thanks for listening
okay
that's good we embarrassed her nicely
thank you everyone
um
so 15 minutes and then we'll open up the
next searing
ah thank you Mr chair
this is one of my bills
this bill was a request of the staff of
the joint legislative committee on
legislative facilities to
clarify the statute and align it more
with current practice
and
that's as much as I know if you have any
questions that can be answered from my
knowledge I'll be I'll try but I've also
brought the Mr Lambert who is the staff
member for for the that committee who
will be able to answer many more than I
would
thank you for your testimony
um you would be willing if if there are
minimal questions you'll consent I'll
try
um do we have
any questions from the committee seeing
none sorry
representative
tyranny thank you for taking my question
um when you say current practices
whose current practices
or what current practices that's one of
the reasons that we needed to have a
bill because the if you read the statute
it says that the Senate and the House of
Representatives shall proposed by a rule
this which in this session was not done
in the house I am not sure whether or
not it was done in the Senate but I tend
to doubt it
because the
um
it's not clear that the joint
legislative facility committee has the
authority to order the house to adopt a
specific rule in fact I would say
offhand they don't have that Authority
well look Mr chairman
okay basically from what I can see on
this one
the only
real change to it
is where it drops the prior to the
beginning of each biennium the committee
shall determine whether it's proposed to
the Senate and House of Representatives
that each body show proposed by rule
that all legislators legislative
officers and legislative staff shall
attend in person
that seems to be all that's gone
um yes I believe that is the case and
um I know I got an email I'm gonna
presume the rest of the folks did here
from an individual with the last name of
Anastasia or Anastasia however they
pronounce it asking to vote against this
simply because it takes the teeth out of
it
making it mandatory for everyone to
attend uh training in person
yes that's true there there I like to
mention two things that you need to
consider okay the first is that
it says each body shall propose by rule
the house or Senate can take this
proposed Rule and turn it down there's
nothing in the current statute that says
they can't
that's one point
and the other is that like I said the
[Music]
um
the committee does not have the
authority to tell the whole house what
it can or cannot do
that's a widely known legal practice
that a committee cannot cannot act for
the whole
um
and so therefore we don't want to have
it in our statute something that is
that the Supreme Court has been has
determined is unconstitutional
thank you
further questions
I have one
um short one
um
we've also crossed out on here the uh
that the policy shall be
um
posted
in the booklet
is that because
the Ethics Committee that produces the
booklet is not responsible for
any rules that have been except for
those that have been passed by the Full
House and this was only passed by the
joint facilities committee uh I'm afraid
I don't know why it is not in the book
okay
thank you
um any other comments questions not
seeing none I think maybe my question
would be best for Mr Lambert uh thank
you for your testimony
I have a second pink card
um for Rich Lambert could you
help us please
you indicate that you're neutral I'm not
for or against the bill you're here to
provide information as a staff person I
can't advocate for policy
and right now actually I can't I don't
have a specific new message from the
Ethics Committee because next Monday
they will be discussing this and the
recusal bill
but I did discuss this with chairman Ned
Gordon and he said
one thing that if the committee feels
that um
the Ethics Committee should have
jurisdiction over this policy which
begins on page 51 of our booklet
then it should stay in the booklet
but the question is
the Ethics Committee have a jurisdiction
over enforcing this policy
so they're looking for clarity
uh
thank you Mr Lambert
um you'll take a question or two if we
have them
are there any questions
from the committee I have one I noticed
on that page that you mentioned
at least when I found it before
it's part um
part five right yes
um
that at one time it used to say
as approved approved it actually says on
page 57.
um approved January 5th 2016 by The
Joint legislative facilities committee
does that mean
to us or should that mean to us that
this was never voted on by the Full
House
it was adopted only by the facilities
committee and therefore it's your belief
that
or or the belief of the Ethics Committee
that this does not
uh fall within their duties
I don't think they've reached that
conclusion they would like to know they
want some clarity and I prepared this a
handout so this policy includes both
sexual harassment but it's much broader
it includes other types of harassment
and other issues discrimination and such
and several complaints have been founded
on by alleged violation of that
and so the committee has tried to work
its way through this but
this is a policy it's not a rule and
it's not a law
and in the handout I provided
it shows that yes sexual harassment is
established by law something that the
Ethics Committee can take jurisdiction
over if someone files a complaint
but then on the next page we see that
the definition of rule is that has been
Limited
and this isn't even a rise to the level
of being a rule it's a policy from
facilities
and
the supporting information here about
the legislative history a little bit
very short about um when that change to
the committee's jurisdiction occurred
and the committee report
saying that it clarif it seeks to
clarify the committee's jurisdiction in
terms of rules so page three
and then I included minutes from a
committee's meeting where it discussed
all of this with the speaker and
representative Wallner
and so the committee would like to know
clearly if this is something that is
intended for the committee type
jurisdiction over
thank you
um does the committee
how did the committee handle complaints
that came to it
out of this part five
it I'm trying to think of it there was
one complaint that went public and that
was a complaint against Representatives
palane
and
part of that was
um
they did
use language in the policy and coming to
their decision
because I mean there's a broader
section two of the statute which says
you know the committee should have the
jurisdiction over manners which reflect
negatively on the legislature so that's
a very broad Grant
so the committee though is asking for
clarification more than anything else
and and does this house bill 157 provide
the clarification that you're looking
for no
does that mean that we would need
to amend I I guess I answered my own
question we would need to amend this in
order to provide Clarity for the Ethics
Committee to handle complaints of this
nature yes they can handle the sexual
harassment complaints it's one of the
two avenues that
um an alleged victim could take or they
could take the other Avenue of
the accounting office and the the
person designated to handle those the
independent Human Resources professional
or you can file a complaint with the
committee so that they know about that
that's clear but these other types of
discrimination or use of hate speech and
so forth which are mentioned in the
policy they're not certain that they
have and I think
they would like a decision made or maybe
this could be more explicit more
specific
does the um
does the committee I don't even know if
it has an official name but this
specific committee that the the speaker
um I always call it the speakers
committee but I have no idea what its
official term is speakers Advisory Group
does that enter into this as well and
are they looking also for guidance on
how to that I don't know about maybe
okay
I'll do things get do things get
referred to them from the Ethics
Committee
they could I don't think they did that
yet things have been referred to the
Ethics Committee from sag okay but the
Ethics Committee hasn't done the
opposite going the other way so we would
have to decide as a committee which
Avenue would be best or or which group
would be best to handle those types of
complaints yes
um
does this sound like something I'm
saying to the committee does this sound
like something we need a work session on
to or a subcommittee uh to deal with
um especially if we are asking the
Ethics Committee and they they would
well I should almost ask representative
wall
um if they are able to provide us the
language that
um would generate the direction of or
the pathway for how these complaints are
held correct
yes they've I'm not I can't predict what
they will decide next week okay
I think we need to uh like we did before
I think we need to wait and see how the
Ethics Committee
um meets and discusses
um they will also bring this up in their
meeting this this Bill yes and we can
use this as a vehicle to do what it is
we want to do all right um I'm good
anyone else have uh further questions
concerns
comments
being none uh thank you very much Mr
Lambert I have no other pink cards is
there anyone
in the extensive audience that would
like to uh
further testify
we're good thanks very much closing the
hearing on House Bill 157
and we have
15 minutes
on my microphone sorry about that thank
you committee chair and committee
members my name is representative Santo
nastasso representing Rindge Jaffrey in
Dublin
and I'm here today to introduce uh house
concurrent resolution six
so this bill addresses a pressing issue
that affects us all the right to
self-determination the fundamental
principle that all people have the right
to govern themselves is one that has
been fought for throughout history
yet despite centuries of warfare we have
made no progress towards this end we've
still witnessed instances where
governments use violence and military
action against those who seek to govern
themselves
it is important to remember that no
government is Justified in using
violence against its own citizens or any
other group of people seeking
self-governments the use of such tactics
is a clear violation of Human Rights an
attack on the basic principles of
freedom and liberty it is a stark
reminder of the oppressive regime
regimes of the past and serves a warning
of what will can happen if we do not
uphold the values of democracy and
self-determination
initiating violence against those who
seek to govern themselves is not only a
barbaric act but also goes against the
very essence of what it means to live in
a free Society it sends a message of
fear and intimidation and undermines the
fundamental rights of individuals to
choose their own destiny
we must acknowledge that the right to
self-determination is not just a
political issue but a moral one as well
it is our duty to stand up for the
rights of all people regardless of their
race religion or nationality we must
support those who seek to govern
themselves and to help create a world
where all individuals have the
opportunity to live in Peace and Freedom
all this bill does is affirm that
military action against those who choose
to self-govern is never appropriate
uh I implore you to join me in
supporting the right to
self-determination for all people let us
work together to create a world where
freedom and liberty are guaranteed and
where the use of violence and military
action is never Justified against those
in the pursuit of self-governance
and a couple of things about this bill
it's very simple it just says that
government is not justifying the use of
uh military action against those who
want to self-govern
um there's a lot of misconceptions what
what that actually means is just that
um and if people do wish to self-govern
I just want to point out that as I
noticed notice in the uh Declaration of
Independence
that they wrote that um
you know experience hath shown that
mankind are more disposed to Suffer Well
Evils are sufferable than to write
themselves by abolishing the forms of
what they're accustomed so the reason
why I bring that up is because what
they're saying is basically
people aren't going to want to
self-govern they're not going to want to
go against uh government and start a new
one except in extreme cases if you know
they'll suffer some evils while they're
while they are sufferable like it says
in the Declaration of Independence uh so
that's uh my testimony for this and I
will take questions
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
seeing none uh thank you very much thank
you
um house we'll call
um
Matt uh Simon D cheniere
schwannier
apologize for
my pronunciation but welcome to
legislative Administration thank you sir
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee my name is Matt saborandi
schwannier I am from Seabrook New
Hampshire I am the chairman of the New
Hampshire Independence political action
committee we support legislation that
yields a proper relationship with the
federal government and leads to one day
an independent New Hampshire we are
proud to support this house concurrent
resolution thank you for having me today
I believe this let's just I believe this
legislation to be very self-explanatory
the bill is actually not about New
Hampshire where 29 of the population
supports Independence today 42 supports
a vote
or even other states and territories in
America and around the world today
exhibiting a desire for autonomy such as
the Texas nationalist movement the yes
California initiative the Puerto Rican
nationalist Party The Divide New York
caucus or free Tibet
it's about being committed to our
founding principles this resolution
it's about respecting boundaries
relationships and human rights
it's about recognizing that when after
some time participating in the social
contract with others
it might be preferable for one group to
dissolve
the relationship it has with another
and to explore A New Path in identity
sometimes we fall out of love with a
person and remain together because we
like the idea of the relationship more
than the person itself
upon recognition of this feeling a
mature constructive course of action
that is respectful of both parties
should be taken
in 1995 the world witnessed our neighbor
to the north Quebec vote to remain in
Canada a decade later in 2014 the world
also witnessed Scotland vote to remain
in the United Kingdom
two years following the United Kingdom
itself voted to leave the European Union
what these three events have in common
is that those votes of self-governance
were allowed to happen without duress
with the people of each Nation freely
expressing their will Freedom includes
the freedom to leave only six percent of
Americans support using military action
against any state in the Union that
expresses a desire to secede
I'm asking you all today to support
article 7 of the New Hampshire state
constitution the article that reinforces
state sovereignty and as well as the
sovereignty of all future States and
pursuance worldwide
thank you
thank you uh you have written
testimonies
I read I read from my script it's marked
up with notes uh would you like it sir
or I would you could submit it um after
this yes okay cool um you will take
questions if we have any
yes yes are there any questions
seeing none uh thank you very much for
your testimony thank you sir thank you
the third pink card I have and the final
pink card
um is uh from representative Jason
Gearhart uh representing Northfield and
Franklin uh and you support the bill
thank you chairman members of the
committee
my name is Jason Gerhart and I was
already introduced Northfield Franklin
I was going to take a little bit of a
different tact on this bill
so to the Constitution for a second
write a revolution just briefly I'll
quote therefore whenever the ends of
government perverted and public Liberty
manifestly endangered and all other
means of redress are ineffectual
the people may and of right ought to
reform the old or establish a new
government the doctrine of
non-resistance against arbitrary power
and oppression is absurd slavish
instructive of the good and happiness of
mankind
if the members of this committee vote
against this bill being as simple as it
is there's no confusion what's going on
I would argue that they are
upholding White Privilege which we must
stamp out because how is it that New
Hampshire has the ability to declare
their right to live
free of absurd government overreach but
we're telling people in the rest of the
world you know what you can't do that
either we can and everyone can and be
self-determination of their their
futures or we're saying that somehow due
to geopolitical rationale you can be
free you can't be free today we like a
country in Eastern Europe separating
tomorrow we won't I think dishing field
and across the board says these
principles are Universal
people
have the right to revolt against the
government that is not serving them that
is oppressing them and as representative
representative Santa saso say people
will not make this step lightly
throughout history it's been very
expensive
but I do feel that we need to let people
know that if they were to make that
decision New Hampshire will not support
using violence against them that is the
key aspect of this you can make all the
Declarations that you know you shouldn't
separate fine but the day you start
shooting at people for saying no we do
not want to be part of this government
that does not represent our interests
I think that's an important thing to say
and
I strongly support the bill would be
willing to hear any questions from
people as to why they maybe are on the
fence I this is kind of important it's
very simple so if there's opposition I'd
really like to hear what it is so thank
you very much thank you representative
um for your testimony are there any
questions for the representative
do you have written testimony
um seeing none uh thank you very much
for your help thank you
foreign
I'm assuming would like to testify
I will
I'm sorry
did anyone sign in
yep it's blind
blue sheet is blank
um
I'm going to close the hearing on hcr6
that does conclude all of our bills
what would also what would we like to do
um we can do that
okay
um I heard that there were some
um committee members that were having
difficulty with an earlier hour a uh a
nine
is that true
no yes
um does anyone have problems still with
the Monday
no
hmm
I'm sorry how many more Mondays
it's just that that's that's my account
that's my County delegation meetings are
all on Mondays through March like from
now like just so it's just and let them
yeah like starting at 9am from nine to
noon okay
um
missing a fuse okay I just don't want to
miss all of them
just one more it could be just one more
okay
um we
what I'm envisioning I think is um is we
have the ethics meeting next week on a
Monday
um
and then we get into the next week is uh
when
we are supposed to be shut down for that
week right is that right it's the
following one yeah
so we have a we have a session though on
the 14th
day um and the
I so we're oh we're possible on the 20th
to the 24th 20th is a holiday 22nd 23rd
or session
so we're not gonna meet on that week
that I can see right then the following
week is the school week okay so now
we're into the sixth the week of the
sixth
and we need to probably meet I'm going
to say on the sixth okay and do
uh oh
that doesn't look right oh it's just bad
luck
it's bad luck yeah that would be very
very
um
so so we are supposed to be able to
the closing date would be the 15th what
could we meet the 13th that Monday
um
if we have if we have
amendments to these
everything would have to be done
on that day on the 13th are we talking
March I'm sorry yeah yeah
we just went through the whole I'm sorry
yeah I mean it seems silly that we're
here in you know the first week in
February pretty much and and
are we able Mr chairman to look at any
Fridays
not only at Mondays really the only days
I I'm trying to stay away from
um Tuesday and Wednesday because that's
when
Municipal and County and I don't know
what the situation is currently with
environment and AG
but those are Tuesday and Wednesdays
Municipal has been bleeding over into
the Thursdays and typically Thursdays
have been our session days but
that seems to be somewhat
evolving too I mean if we're going on
the 14th
[Music]
um
I don't know
um I I wouldn't have a problem with the
Friday do we have problems you have
problems with the Friday
yeah um
see wow anybody want to be chair
um
well we're just we're suffering from a
little bit of you know holidays get
thrown on Mondays and yep and shutting
off for school vacation week
is the school a vacation week an
automatic no for everyone
or anyone
you're out of the state
hmm
what's next Monday next Monday is when
ethics is meeting at three in the
afternoon
um
yeah it sounds like I need of the of the
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday what's the
best option for anybody
or is there a no option for anybody no
Tuesdays I'm sorry no Tuesdays for me no
Tuesdays so of the Wednesdays and
Thursdays is there is there any that
anyone can't do
we don't want that
um yeah it would depend on
which one you're
attempting to do okay
so
I'm looking at what were the two days
that after the 14th of this this
um session is going to be 23rd
those are the two days that I was
thinking
um
you know
um how about the eighth and Ninth
of March
good
no problems
what day would that be
um that would be Wednesday or Thursday
so here's where I think we have a winner
um I'm assuming Vanessa's okay
um if that it works maybe we can I'll
try to get ahead of
or find out from the other two
committees if I can have either or both
of those days and then um
and then we can
that will give us opportunity
to either clean up something or get the
or get the amendments in and discussed
and and we could probably exec
everything in the afternoon and do the
work session in the morning like we did
today and then be done
and and then it would give us enough
time if it is the eighth Wednesday we
could actually get it in the calendar
right that Wednesday
um which is another
part for us to have to worry about not
you
um but it is um I think that may not be
bad so try to keep the eighth and Ninth
flexible and I will promise that I'll as
quickly as possible get
one of those two days locked in
um so how do you see where it's sucking
when and we're doing Workshop when I
would say exec in the afternoon and
workshop in the morning
and if I try for the uh
I could potentially try to lock in both
days and then
if we don't get something done we can
get it done the next day
I just
right
that's that's the thing I mean if I can
always we can be done and then we don't
have to use the next day
I have to think of a clever way to word
that
um so I'm going to say
that we think of the eighth and Ninth
which is a month from now
which just seems crazy
why would we do anything on the sixth
what's that because it's Monday
because what he mentioned it early on
was it a Monday because it's a Monday
no I don't think we need it I think I
don't remember who's had the problem
with it yeah six six is tough yeah okay
that's why
um
all right I'm gonna say that
um our magic days are the eighth and 9th
and um and we'll try to get everything
done
keep that open as much as you can and if
you have to
keep the afternoon
available so that because the afternoon
will be when we exact not the morning
okay
good all right
um unless anybody has anything else to
deal with I'm going to uh
lock up for the day thank you very much
for all your questions